>> NEW REPORTING PROVIDED TO CNN
BY THE FOURTH BOOK BY MAGGIE
HABERMAN WITH REVELATIONS ON
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FINAL
DAYS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
CHRISTIANE HOLMES HAS ALL THE
NEW DETAILS AND THERE ARE
BOMBSHELLS HERE.
>> THERE ARE.
ACCORDING TO MAGGIE'S REPORTING,
IN THE FINAL DAYS TRUMP INSISTED
HE WOULD NOT BE LEAVING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS LEFT AIDES CONFUSED AND
UNCERTAIN AS TO WHAT HE WOULD DO
NEXT.
NEW REVELATIONS ON THE FINAL
DAYS OF FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY.
IN REPORTING PROVIDE TO CNN FROM
A BOOK BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTER MAGGIE HABERMAN TRUMP
TOLD AIDES HE WOULD REFUSE TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> THIS IS A FRAUD ON THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
THIS IS AN EMBARRASSMENT TO OUR
COUNTRY.
WE WERE GETTING READY TO WIN
THIS ELECTION.
FRANKLY, WE DID WIN THIS
ELECTION.
>> HABERMAN'S BOOK, "CONFIDENCE
MAN THE MAKING OF DONALD TRUMP
AND THE BREAKING OF AMERICA"
REPORTS TRUMP TOLD ONE AIDE,
QUOTE, I'M JUST NOT GOING TO
LEAVE.
AND SAYING TO ANOTHER, QUOTE,
WE'RE NEVER LEAVING HOW CAN YOU
LEAVE WHEN YOU WON AN ELECTION.
TRUMP'S INSISTENCE HE WOULD NOT
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE HAS NEVER
BEEN REPORTED AND SHINES A LIGHT
ON THE FINAL DAYS OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
HABERMAN WRITES OF A SHIFT IN
HIS COMMENTS.
IN THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF
THE 2020 ELECTION TRUMP SEEMED
TO RECOGNIZE THE LOSS.
HE COMFORTED ONE ADVISER SAYING
WE DID OUR BEST AND TELLING
JUNIOR PRESS AIDES I THOUGHT WE
HAD IT.
SEEMINGLY ALMOST EMBARRASSED BY
THE OUTCOME.
>> IF THEY DO ELECT PRESIDENT
ELECT JOE BIDEN ARE YOU NOT
GOING TO LEAVE THIS BUILDING?
>> CERTAINLY I WILL.
YOU KNOW THAT.
I THINK THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
THINGS HAPPENING BETWEEN NOW AND
THE 20th OF JANUARY.
>> BUT AT SOME POINT HIS MOOD
SHIFTED AND HE WAS HEARD SAYING
HE WOULD NOT LEAVE.
AND HE WAS HEARD ASKING THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE
CHAIR, WHY SHOULD I LEAVE IF
THEY STOLE IT FROM ME?
>> MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS
ELECTION WAS STOLEN FROM YOU,
THE ME, THE COUNTRY.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
STATES, THE ELECTION WAS TOTALLY
RIGGED.
>> HABERMAN REPORTS TRUMP
QUIZZED NEARLY EVERYONE AROUND
HIM ON HOW TO STAY IN POWER.
AMONG THOSE WHO REPORTED ASKED,
THE VALET THAT BROUGHT HIM A
DIET COKE WHEN HE ASKED.
SHE SAID JARED KUSHNER WAS
RELUCTANT TO CONFRONT HIM OVER
THE ELECTION LOSS.
HE ENCOURAGED A GROUP OF AIDS TO
GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHEN ASKED WHY HE WOULDN'T
SAYING ANYTHING, HE LIKENED IT
TO A DEATHBED SCENE SAYING THE
PRIEST COMES LATER.
>> THIS COMES AS THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
JANUARY 6th IS PLANNING MORE
HEARINGS IN THE FALL AND AS
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS ISSUED A
NUMBER OF SUBPOENAS TO TRUMP
AIDES IN RECENT DAYS AND WEEKS.
THE OTHER INTERESTING TWIST WE
LEARNED THAT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP LANDED AT AN AIRPORT
OUTSIDE OF D.C.
WE'RE TOLD HE'S GOING TO HIS
GOLF CLUB IN VIRGINIA, BUT IT'S
NOTABLE BECAUSE IT'S ONLY THE
SECOND TIME HE VISITED THE D.C.
AREA SINCE HE LEFT OFFICE.
>> THANK YOU FOR SHARING THOSE
HEADLINES WITH US.
ROMAN, IT'S INTERESTING -- THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
INTERESTING BUT IT'S ALSO
INTERESTING THAT INITIALLY HE
SEEMED TO UNDERSTAND THAT HE
LOST THE ELECTION.
EVENTUALLY THAT OBVIOUSLY
SHIFTED BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE OF INTEREST TO
INVESTIGATORS.
>> RIGHT WHEN IT DID SHIFT, IF
HE WAS TELLING PEOPLE I'M NOT
GOING TO LEAVE, THE LEGAL MATTER
AT PLAY IS WHAT DID THESE PEOPLE
DO WITH IT?
HOW DID THEY INTERPRET IT AND
WHAT DID THEY DO?
THIS IS ANOTHER DATA POINT AS
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE RAMPS
UP HEARINGS THIS MONTH.
IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT.